[Music]
in the early 1920s a businessman in
boston had a realization everybody wants
to get rich without doing any work so
this businessman came up with a
brilliant idea to make a lot of money
and like all good fit and sears he
promised to make those around him really
rich too the businessman told his
investors he was buying discounted
coupons in foreign countries and making
money reselling them in the u.s it was a
middleman opportunity that he claimed
was totally safe and guaranteed a return
the businessman promised his investors a
50 profit in 45 days or a hundred
percent in 90 days what this businessman
was doing was paying the people who got
in early with the money for the people
who got in later those later investors
excited by hearing about a guaranteed
high return investment were left holding
the bag that businessman was named
charles ponzi his name has become
synonymous with these sorts of schemes
this ponzi scheme made millions of
dollars in just a few months but such a
con can only go on for so long
eventually you run out of other people's
money and for ponzi when that happens
you go to jail
a hundred years later a new bunch of
wealthy investors say they too have a
brilliant way to make you a lot of money
they promise to make you really really
rich
the best part is they say the returns
are guaranteed anyone can buy with any
amount of money it's called bitcoin
bitcoin is a digital token with no
physical or government backing that's
run by a global decentralized network of
computers these computers keep track of
every bitcoin transaction and can move
bitcoins easily from one user to another
there are a limited number of bitcoins
in the world 21 million 19 million of
which have already been mined
these mining rigs are large systems of
computers which perform complex
calculations expending huge amounts of
energy to create new bitcoins massive
bitcoin mining farms are set up in
places like siberia and northeastern
china where people take advantage of
cheap electricity in massive wasteful
facilities but how bitcoin works doesn't
really matter that much all the stuff
you hear about peer-to-peer technology
and the blockchain really only explains
how bitcoin works as a currency but
despite the name bitcoin isn't really
used much as a currency at all when
people buy bitcoin they rarely use it to
buy goods and services
they're really buying access to a ponzi
scheme
only 1.3 of bitcoin's economic activity
is in merchant transactions the rest is
speculation people buying it just
because they think it will go up and the
more it's used in speculation the less
incentive people have to actually use it
as a currency
why buy something with bitcoin when you
can hold it and make some easy money
that's why the peak of bitcoin being
used to buy things was actually back in
2017
before its price really took off and the
currency should be stable in value not
bounce all over the place the way
bitcoin does
rises are nice but bitcoin also falls a
lot if you want to speculate that's fine
that's your own business
but you don't want the value of your
checking account to gyrate wildly and
unpredictably just because elon musk has
tweeted about it if you have friends or
relatives who are into cryptocurrency
you know that the reason that people are
into bitcoin is because they think it
can make them a lot of money
because bitcoin is just a digital token
without any inherent value they're not
really making an investment they're
engaging in a financial betting game
anything you invest in bitcoin or
ethereum or dogecoin just goes into the
pocket of the previous holder there's no
real income generating asset behind it
what they're betting on is that other
people will bet on it and the value will
keep going up if more people are joining
the market you can make money you're not
a sucker if the person next in line is a
sucker too
and as long as you can make it out on
time the next guy is left holding the
bag the good news for these gamblers is
that there are a lot of suckers in the
world
the bad news is that eventually you run
out of suckers so to keep the scam
running as long as they can the wealthy
proponents of bitcoin say that it's
changing the world they say that bitcoin
is going to replace fiat currencies like
the dollar they say that it's going to
undermine cruel dictatorships and greedy
banks and help usher in a libertarian
utopia of privacy and security
and most importantly they say what every
scam artist has said since the beginning
of time get in right now and you'll make
quick and easy money don't miss out on
this once in a lifetime opportunity and
for the last few years they've actually
been right if you'd spend a hundred
dollars in buying shares of apple in
january 2016 you'd have about 540 bucks
now if you spent that hundred dollars on
bitcoin then you'd have made more than
nine thousand dollars
but that doesn't mean that bitcoin is
working
it means that a lot of people have
fallen for the scam
and the more people who buy it the more
the price fluctuates and the less usable
it is as a currency the success of
bitcoin as a speculative commodity has
made it socially useless you'd actually
have made just as much money buying a
parody cryptocurrency called dogecoin
that makes none of the grandiose claims
that bitcoin does in fact it explicitly
started as a joke
meanwhile as more and more people
speculate on bitcoin it consumes more
and more electricity and emits more and
more carbon because of how complex
bitcoin transactions are they consume an
incredible amount of power
one bitcoin transaction consumes more
electricity than the average american
household does in a month
bitcoin as a whole consumes more
electricity than entire countries
venezuela bangladesh pakistan kazakhstan
and the philippines
if bitcoin ever were to be widely
adopted it would consume many times more
energy than is produced in the world
today bitcoin isn't useful at all except
maybe is a symbol of how capitalism has
changed from something that could once
build factories and transcontinental
railroads to a system of pure
speculation totally divorced in the real
world look at this system millions of
computers emitting huge amounts of
carbon making pointless calculations in
order to gain access to a digital token
with no actual use all while the
infrastructure crumbles and people go
hungry
this is a terrible way to organize a
society but because bitcoin is a ponzi
scheme without any benefit to society
does not mean it's going away bitcoin
has become a culture an identity amid
the vast meaninglessness of a society in
decline a lot of people find value in it
in a world where traditional forms of
identity are in decline family unions
religion new ones like cryptocurrencies
spring up to take their place the fact
that so many lonely atomized people find
community and meaning in bitcoin means
that for the people at the very top
people with millions or even billions of
dollars there's a ready and willing
community of suckers to exploit you can
still make money off cryptocurrencies in
an age of low wages and mass
underemployment people will always be
lured by the promise of getting rich
quick but there will always be somebody
left holding the bag and it could very
well be you
in essence bitcoin is a gamble gambling
can be fun at low stakes with friends
but the people trying to sell you
bitcoin aren't your friends no matter
what you tell yourself you're just
gambling not that an asset has value but
that the person next in line is more
gullible than you
this is doug henwood author of wall
street for the gravel institute
[Music]
[Music]
you